played one father speaking out telling
us he and his autistic son were asked to
leave because of his son's behavior
madison kimbrough getting answers for us
as well as reaction from the
establishment she joins us live on the
strip madison
this happened last night as daniel
jimenez says he and his family were
treated horribly here at the pinball
hall of fame that's near las vegas
boulevard near russell all because his
child who is on the spectrum wouldn't be
still
i understand please tell me tell me tell
me my son who is autistic cannot spin
you tell him you cannot spin inside
you're laughing at me
this is video provided to eight news now
from an altercation that happened
thursday night at the pinball hall of
fame daniel jimenez says they were asked
to leave because of his seven-year-old
son's behavior the owner of the
establishment approached me and said ask
me to tell my son who is
on the spectrum
to stop spinning jimenez's son danny is
autistic and spinning is how he copes
with his surroundings i asked him to
show me the rules he said he's a private
club and he can make up the rules daniel
says words were exchanged and in the
short interaction police were called
nobody should be treated the way
we should be we were treated no one
whether it be disabilities or
able-bodied children no one should be
treated that way and this is a family
establishment he believes he was
discriminated against because of his
son's disability i reached out to the
pinball hall of fame the president tim
arnold tells me the business may be
perceived as a kid's attraction but says
it's actually a dangerous place for
quote active children there's a list of
things we don't allow at any time for
anybody whether they're handicapped or
fully able arnold says he and his staff
are trained to work with all types of
kids including those with autism but the
problem on thursday wasn't the child but
his parent if his child would slip and
fall the concrete would knock a hole in
his head i kept telling him please sir
take your child to a safer place all he
could keep saying was my child has
autism i don't understand what that has
to do with simple safety rules
jimenez says another family that was
trying to help them were also told to
leave too as for what's next jimenez is
looking into legal action reporting near
las vegas boulevard and russell madison
kimbrough live local now